it's always nice to see your friends
again even if your time together doesn't
always live up to the highest highs
you've experienced in the past
persona 5 strikers is a lot like that it
comes with some special moments that
foster a deeper appreciation for what
persona 5
is and what it represents from the wild
action rpg combat to the summer road
trip premise
characters we know and love get to show
off how much they've grown and prove
they can still kick ass in style
strikers does fall into a few clumsy
tropes along the way and sometimes it
tries a little too hard to recapture
persona 5's magic but when it's all said
and done
i'm glad this reunion happened to begin
with
yeah summer vacation here we come
it's summer vacation after the events of
the original game but before they can
even make plans they're caught in
another round of fighting evil in the
metaverse
and changing hearts this time it's all
across japan
strikers follows a similar flow
established in persona 5 but the context
is quite different both narratively and
gameplay-wise
your first few targets have been
manipulating people's desires in order
to feed their own ambitions
but there's a bigger mystery as to how
and why there's strange behavior in mass
you begin to unveil that tragic paths
have led them down a dark path of
exploiting the metaverse
the broader message isn't to excuse
their behavior or to say that trauma
will surely corrupt its victims
rather that our circumstances and the
people around us or
lack thereof significantly influences
how we internalize and process
pain through each story beat the main
cast relates to these tragic situations
because of what they went through in the
original game
is she beyond helping at this point
i don't know but there has to be someone
who at least
tries we can't just abandon alice
oh lady on it shows just how much our
fellow phantom thieves have grown since
the events of persona
5 and strikers gives them the
opportunity to impart their wisdom
onto others however the story doesn't
always hit these topics with particular
nuance
leaving some of its messaging feeling a
bit shallow dialogue sometimes relies on
surface level exposition or talking in
circles to belabor a point
many of the villains are avatars for a
type of character flaw in a very
matter-of-fact way
and i felt somewhat detached to the
stakes at times although it's not
deliberately explored in depth
persona 5 strikers does have a
surprisingly poignant message about the
role of technology in our lives
the perks the pitfalls the power it
affords certain people
and how it can be abused and as usual
with persona the story also presents
human connection as a source of strength
and by the end of the journey those
themes come into clearer focus this
extends to the new characters who are
great additions and fit well alongside
the phantom thieves
yo phantom thieves
what is that
i am sophia humanity's companion
sophia is the cutesy artificial
intelligence a siri-like phone companion
who takes human form to fight in the
metaverse
her bubbly attitude and gradual
understanding of human mannerisms gives
a warm vibe
everything should go
and we'll have access zenkichi is a
goofball adult but as an inspector with
japan's public security he's an
authority figure that everyone
rightfully distrusts
sorry about that we just despise the
police's off
but his growth is key to persona 5's
themes like defying flawed institutions
in order to make things right which also
helps him rebuild a relationship with
his daughter
the integration of sophia and zenkichi
only feels natural and that's due in
large part to how strikers builds the
story around them
yeah you really came through gramps i
knew we could count on you gramps son
come on guys at least call me by my name
don't feel bad gramps
now this is summer vacation so with an
rv on hand and makoto with a driver's
license this becomes your home away from
home on this road trip
from the sun-soaked beaches of okinawa
to the bustling city center of dotenbury
it's exciting to share the experience of
touring japan with these characters
even though there isn't much to do in
these cities other than shop for items
or talk to npcs and your companions
taking in the scenery is pretty sweet
it's much lighter on the social
simulation elements though you do have
things called requests where you can
take on side objectives
and spend bond points to increase perks
that you can take into battle
there is a calendar that acts as a
timeline for the story but absent are
the pressures of deadlines hanging over
your head you can also leave and enter
dungeons at any checkpoint to recuperate
without penalty
it serves to tighten the narrative but
also creates a more carefree vibe
after all the battles and tragedies that
the phantom thieves overcame
it's nice to see them enjoy life even as
they continue fighting against the
looming evil
it's not always smooth sailing though at
times strikers falls into cringy tropes
that undermine its ethos
for example one villain's metaverse form
is an overweight caricature
using obesity as shorthand for evil it
doesn't even make sense in context
there's also not one but two bath house
scenes that put the female cast in
uncomfortable situations as a
meaningless gag also we can stop picking
on my boy
so ryuji snap out of it ryuji
we're about to head in i know i know
i was so excited last night i couldn't
sleep what you think it's christmas
morning or something
with most of these characters having
troubled pass i'd rather not see them
being treated unfairly amongst friends
with each stop across japan there's work
to be done and the way strikers
faithfully incorporates persona 5's rpg
mechanics and its lavish style
for frenetic musou style action made me
eager to put in that work
you'll explore dungeons as you would in
persona 5 sneaking up on shadows for
ambushes or confronting them to initiate
battles and you jump straight into
real-time action
each character has their own elemental
affinities persona abilities
and unique attack combos you can swap
between any one of the four in your
party to take direct control and make
the most of their capabilities
while you can stop time by pulling up
spells combat moves so quickly that you
need to be consistently attacking or
dodging as you devise ways to exploit
enemy weaknesses
it's a lot to take in for the first few
hours of the game tutorials are late on
thick but battles got chaotic before i
had a firm grasp of things
but the various mechanics started to
make sense and as i began to form
general combat strategies i was just
itching to start fights it's so
satisfying to tear through mobs of
shadows while juggling the challenge of
tougher enemies that hit harder and have
a ton of hp
you can't necessarily get away with
spamming spells it's best to learn how
to use characters specific elemental
combos that are free of sp
cost combine that with a variety of
personas and joker's roster
earning all-out attack opportunities and
executing showtime attacks
you'll feel unstoppable when it all
comes together
each character has their personality and
charm come through with how they
function in battle too
you can even directly control them
during dungeon exploration which is a
sweet touch that lets your favorite
character be the star of your show now
as gratifying as the big fights are this
is a somewhat inelegant combat system
things can get messy when there's an
overwhelming amount to parse on screen
making it hard to telegraph enemy
attacks
and this can pile on in a moment's
notice for devastating results
also the more story focused fights
suffered from having active dialogue
overlapping with each other while other
audio cues
and sound effects and music were layered
on as well and it got overbearing
when it comes to dungeon designs they
work well enough although they rely on
basic formats and aren't nearly as
imaginative as they are in persona 5.
what is an annoyance however is that the
flow is often interrupted by superfluous
dialogue that overexplains each step of
the dungeon's progress
all things considered combat is a
definite highlight strikers
is a strong adaptation and
representation of persona 5's gameplay
qualities
at its best i couldn't help but feel
that persona 5 was always a great match
for action-based combat
now whether you're in combat or going
about your tasks the striker's
soundtrack is going to steal your heart
music is integral to persona's identity
and yet again
the atlas sound team manages to impress
and build on the tremendous work from
persona 5.
old favorites like last surprise and
rivers in the desert have metal and punk
style arrangements with up-tempo
percussion
and carry a new attitude to perfectly
match the chaotic action
the new battle theme what you wish for
is an instant classic with upbeat acid
jazz rock style
each town you visit comes with new
comforting background songs too
one standout being okinawa which
features islander instrumentals and
borrows a melody from the persona 5
anime credit song called infinity
the soundtrack also touches on symphonic
metal but also dark and heavy electronic
tunes
but no song will sell you on the
soundtrack quite like daredevil
it carries the same vibe as life will
change but with a more aggressive
attitude
backed by groovy disco metal
instrumentation and lynn's incredible
vocals
this soundtrack showcases the range of
atlas sound team
and also their ability to make music
that stirs up the spectrum of emotions
and become inseparable from the
experience now once i reach the final
hours of strikers
i was reminded of persona's ability to
create an unmistakable sense of finality
many parts of this game are quite goofy
or hammy but when things come together
towards the end
and the music kicks in at the right time
my heart was fully in it
strikers has a deep cast of characters
and the way it brings the entire crew
together for these final moments
makes the phantom thieves feel whole
everyone puts in the work and everyone
shines in their own right as they finish
the fight
ending the journey on a high note so for
all of its shortcomings
persona 5 strikers reminds me of why i
love the phantom thieves to begin with
and shows us how much they've grown
since we last saw them
once you get your head around it the
action rpg combat is a challenging
thrill
and no one can pull it off in the same
fashion as these characters
i almost forgot i was playing a muso
style game developed by koei tekmo no
megaforce
i think that's a testament to how sharp
strikers is as a persona game
if you have any love for persona 5 would
say you saved the world one more time
with some old friends
thank you